All right.
I hate that I have to do this today, but there's
been a sort of personal
thing that relates to the show going on the
last 24 hours that I want to tell you about
because it is once again just this is the
worst type of stuff that I have to deal with
as host of this show.
Um, I am the David Pakman show are now under
attack by a so-called left wing activists,
really sort of a centrist democratic activist.
And this came up out of nowhere yesterday
with no warning.
And quite frankly, um, I, I need everybody's
support here.
So let me tell you the story from the beginning
indulged me, uh, just for a few minutes and
everybody will be caught up.
Back in December of 2018, a woman named Amy
Siskind tweeted on her Twitter account quote,
I will not support white male candidates in
the democratic primary unless you slept through
midterms.
Women were our most successful candidate,
biggest Dem vote getters in history.
Obama Oh eight, Hillary 16 white male is not
where our party is at and is our least safe
option in 2020.
Now, of course, the biggest Dem vote getters,
peace ignores that.
When the population grows over time you would
expect candidates to get more and more raw
votes.
But forget about the math issue.
To me, the idea that was tweeted here is the
opposite of progressive.
She is saying that on the basis of race and
gender, she's ruling out supporting certain
candidates, white male candidates.
That's terrible.
I don't agree with that.
Now a side note, Amy Siskin was a big Hillary
supporter in 2016 that's sort of her placement
within the democratic party and the left.
Um, uh, and, and that's fine.
She's part of the Hillary wing of the party,
uh, which shows she's perfectly well allowed
to do and that has nothing to do with the
criticism that I responded with.
So at the time I replied, isn't there something
not progressive about preemptively dismissing
a candidate based on their race and gender?
I feel like there's a word to describe that
as a progressive.
I won't be jumping on board with that idea.
And at the time, remember this is 2018 Amy
Siskin responded to me, quote, secure men
are always at the forefront of diversity.
They don't see their place or status threatened
by lifting women, people of color or people
of all sexual orientations because they are
comfortable with themselves suggesting I'm
neither secure and are comfortable with myself
or uncomfortable, you know, lifting women
or people of color.
And I responded once again, that's exactly
right and I'm 100 on board with that.
It seems to be the exact opposite of preemptively
disqualifying candidates on the basis of race
or gender.
Now, tons of people saw this exchange and
started re-tweeting it and by the next morning,
Amy Siskin had blocked me on Twitter the next
day I tweeted about this saying the intolerant
left is small but horrible.
Amy Siskins said she wouldn't vote for anyone
white or male.
In 2020 I pointed out, this is the definition
of racism and sexism.
I respectfully questioned her approach.
She blocked me.
This set her into an absolute rage.
And in addition to having blocked me on Twitter,
she sought me out on Facebook at the time
she found me on Facebook and left me the following
message on my personal Facebook account where
she said, quote, remember I was teaching as
an adjunct at Boston college shortly before
this, she says, I called Boston college to
launch a complaint that you should not be
teaching young minds, but they said you do
not teach there.
I reported you anyway because you should not
be invited back.
May want to update your Facebook page to reflect
reality.
Now of course, I taught at BC in 2017.
Facebook reflected that as an adjunct.
I'm not permanently employed BC, so if you
call them during the semester where I'm not
teaching, they would say he doesn't work here
right now.
And so she was right, man, these are her words.
She said she called BC and told them that
I should not be teaching there.
This became quite a story.
Joe Rogan and bill Burr, um, talked about
this exchange that I had with Amy Siskind
on a Joe Rogan's program.
I later went on Joe Rogan's program in June
of 2019 and Joe and I spoke about it and we
put Amy Siskins tweet [inaudible] Joe's producer,
put Amy Siskins tweet up on the screen.
Um, and then I never heard anything about
it again.
Okay.
That was June of 2019.
It's been seven months until yesterday, completely
out of nowhere.
Amy Siskind appears on the David Pakman show
Facebook page and posts, quote, you're a liar,
David.
I never tried to get you fired.
I pointed out your LinkedIn page didn't even
include an adjunct position and you were embellishing.
You owe me in a public apology.
You completely made it up to get attention.
Now, as you can see, this is factually wrong.
Notice in her post in December, she says,
it's my Facebook profile that misstated my
position at Boston college in her post yesterday.
She says she was pointing something out from
LinkedIn.
So clearly she doesn't remember the post.
Uh, I don't know which is accurate.
Was it because of Facebook or because of LinkedIn?
But then she went on to post to our Facebook
page yesterday again, out of nowhere, we haven't
heard from her for for six, seven months.
She says, quote, someone sent me a link to
an entire segment you did with that openly
racist, transphobic, misogynist Joe Rogan
in which you trashed me for made up.
I never called Boston college.
I never tried to get you fired.
This is a complete fabrication you made up
to get attention.
You must publicly apologize for this lie in
smear.
Now, let me remind you, Amy herself posted
on my Facebook page a quote I called Boston
college to launch a complaint that you should
not be teaching young minds, but they said
you do not teach there.
I reported you anyway because you should not
be invited back and this is where it's getting
ugly.
She is now making threats saying yesterday,
I will give you today to apologize.
Then I will be sharing what you did publicly.
Now, of course I did nothing wrong so I'm
not going to apologize, but people who know
Amy Siskind had been warning me.
She will go after your advertisers.
She will go after the stations that broadcast
your show.
She will lobby free speech TV to drop the
David Pakman show and she has resources behind
her, those sort of centrist establishment,
democratic party resources.
Now anybody who looks at the fact says a C's
in December of 2018 she said, I called Boston
college and told them not to have you teach
there.
She might've been lying back then or she's
lying now, right?
We don't know.
I reached out to Joe Rogan about this since
it relates to the conversation we had on his
show.
He's aware of it.
I've been in touch with our legal team.
We just don't know what to expect right now
and it's a really tough situation because
she does have friends in important places
in the democratic establishment.
She has the type of support that we might
call monied legacy democratic resources.
So I am telling you this not so that you go
out and send Amy Siskind tweets or attacker.
In fact, let me be clear.
Do not do that.
That is not what I am asking anybody to do.
That's not going to help us.
What I am telling you is we may be up against
something big here that could really be damaging
to the show and it'll become a distraction
from the 2020 election coverage.
It will become a distraction from covering
issues, a distraction from the coverage of
the impeachment of the president of the United
States.
I don't know whether this is going to end
up costing big money.
up losing us.
Some of our broadcast platforms, she has connections
in the establishment, legal community, the
establishment, political community, the establishment
media community, people who could make my
life a living hell and demanding an apology
with an ultimatum does not bode particularly
well.
So I'm letting you know what's going on.
Please consider supporting us directly.
Grab a membership@joinedpacman.com she can
lobby our stations to drop the show.
She can't do anything about people who say,
I'm going to support David Pakman directly.
Grab a membership@joinpacman.com use Patrion
patrion.com/david Pakman show.
We do not want to be bullied, but we need
to recognize that she could bring some significant
sort of bully pulpit power against us.
It's horrible.
Um, I, I this has been really stressful over
the last 24 hours.
I will keep
you posted.
That's the full story as I
know
it for now.